pharmaceutical company pfizer says that
an oral drug for covid19 could be ready
next year
pfizer is working on two antivirals an
oral
medication and an injectable the company
started an early stage clinical trial of
the oral drug
last month the drug blocks a critical
enzyme that the virus needs to replicate
it's very interesting here is pfizer ceo
albert borla
talking about this this morning on cnbc
around the summer
what do you think is a reasonable time
frame albert for a small molecule
antiviral pill like that to get through
phase three and actually to get out
there and potentially be available
if all goes well
if all goes well and we implement the
same speed that we did
so far and we are and if regulators
also do the same and they are i hope
by the end of the year in this next clip
they talk about the oral versus the
injectable and again this is albert
albert berla
ceo of pfizer who made 18 million
dollars in total compensation
in 2019 uh let's listen
uh albert there's a in a new york paper
with the post admit they bet covent cure
may be ready this year from the pfizer
drug and it's a it's a
i know you know which one i'm talking
about pf
zero seven three two one three three two
is what it says but
it it prevents a replication of of covet
in the nose and and
it could be an oral medication and
they're calling it a cure could be ready
next year
is that headline accurate
well it is accurate that we are working
in uh antiviral and
we have an actual on two one it is
injectable and the other one as you
said it is an oral and particularly the
intention is on the oral
of the world and of us because provide
several advantages and one of them is
that you don't need to go to the
hospital
to get the treatment which is the case
with all the injectables so far
but you can get it home that could be a
game changer
the compound that you are talking about
and you said very well the numbers
it is a protest inhibitor the good thing
it is that
this is also the first molecule
that is coming from this type of
class this is good thing because you can
combine it
with other classes also the mechanism of
action
it is such that it's not expected to be
subject to mutations particularly
because it's not acting on the
spike as we all know all the mutations
that we are
hearing right now are changes in the
proteins of the spine
so this is not a trivial detail an
antiviral
like what is being developed by pfizer
would not be
as jeopardized by mutations and variants
that's really important
and of course if all goes as described
and there's still much to be determined
here
this could be a real game changer now i
have to tell you
it is not lost on me that as albert
borla is speaking
the stock price of pfizer is on the
screen as their ceo is talking about
medications they may soon have
this is a really stark reminder of the
system that we have and i have addressed
this before
i believe there has to be a middle
ground here on the one hand
we can't allow pharmaceutical companies
to hold us hostage when it comes to our
health
on the other hand i don't expect the
best and brightest minds
to line up to solve our problems as a
charitable contribution i just don't
expect that to happen
the creators of these um
treatments vaccines etc should be
rewarded they really have done something
incredible the the turkish couple
in germany who developed what is now
called the pfizer vaccine
they make a profit by uh doing this
they will then be likely to do it again
and they will be more likely to come up
with
other cures treatments vaccines when the
next pandemic comes around
if there's no profit now who will invest
next
time for now pfizer has increased
revenue about two percent
after investing about 10 billion
researching the
um vaccine they took some risk
of investing in a coveted vaccine they
could have done oncology stuff which has
higher profit margin okay
the same applies to the researchers the
founders of biontech
are now really wealthy but don't we want
people to enter the field of science and
develop things that can be life-saving
but
we need to ensure access we need to look
at government subsidies
and there there's a concept in health
care where
premiums can't exceed benefits by a
certain percentage
or a portion of the premiums have to be
refunded to the consumer maybe allowing
pharmaceutical companies to have a
margin that's
fair but limited would work i don't know
i i'm just thinking out loud there are
certain people
i don't mind seeing being paid
handsomely
right uh my kid if i had kids my kids
teachers and doctors firefighters
people develop developing vaccines to
deal with a pandemic
should the government be involved in
determining a fair price yeah maybe so
but context is crucial here uh bernie
sanders made a statement about this and
he made a statement about vaccine
production and delivery
outside the u.s and allowing other
countries to use the ip the intellectual
property of u.s companies to make
vaccines and
instead of having to wait around for the
u.s companies those are great ideas
the government should be involved but in
a sense
i am more pleased with people involved
in biomedical research making money than
in some other areas now does the ceo
deserve 18 million that's a very
different question
and uh one that that i think we can
fairly
debate and um you know the counter is
always well if you only pay two million
then some mining company will swoop them
up sweep them up instead of
a pharmaceutical company and maybe the
pharmaceutical company will be slower
and
okay okay there's maybe a debate there
but
i think that the the it has to be a
middle path here